On Tuesday I started to talk to you
about trait theory and now I'm going to
make a jump to biology.
And that that's a strange jump in some
sense because the two levels of analysis
are relatively disconnected.
But what's happening right now at the,
at the sort of outer echelons of
personality research is that
okay,
the workers at the forefront of the
field are trying to integrate what's
been established at the statistical
level of analysis with what's known at
the psychobiological level.
And so this emerging science is known as
personality neuroscience.
MMM.
It's developed in a rather strange way
because
the traits that were identified that I
discussed with you on Tuesday,
the big five traits all emerged as a
consequence of the statistical analysis
of,
of descriptors characteristic mostly of
the English language,
although it's been duplicated in other
languages.
So in some sense it was in a theoretical
model,
right?
It just came out of the linguistic data.
So there was no real initial inferences
about brain area or neurological
activity or,
or anything like that to drive the
formulation of the big five model.
And instead the big five model came
first and then people started thinking,
okay,
can this be put into alignment with what
we know about the brain?
And so people have been hitting that
pretty hard.
I would say over about the last,
it's probably 30 years,
something like that because Hans Isaac
and his student,
Jeffrey Gray,
we're pretty far along on this kind of
thinking by say 1982 when gray published
his book,
the neuropsychology of anxiety,
which the paper you're reading now,
a model of the limbic system and Basal
Ganglia,
Basal Ganglia application stay anxiety
and schizophrenia.
That's a very short summary of the book.
That gray published in 1982 which has
been incredibly influential.
Um,
if you're interested in going on in
psychology,
especially on the scientific end,
but I would say pretty much regardless
if you're interested in going on in
psychology,
that's a,
that's a very useful book to tackle.
There's a newer version and it was
published by gray and Mcnaughton and I
think 2000 something like that.
It's hard going,
like,
and you may have found the paper that we
too gray was a very,
very,
unfortunately,
he died a few years ago.
He was a very,
very smart person.
And he knew the animal literature on
behavior,
neuro,
Adam,
neuroanatomy and neuropsychopharmacology
inside out and backwards.
And so whenever he defined a term,
he always made sure that the term was
intelligible at a behavioral level and
at an anatomical level.
And at a pharmacological level,
it had to,
you know,
the,
the ideas that he were developing had to
make sense that these multiple levels of
analysis before he would accept them as,
as genuine and gray did a remarkable job
of extending our knowledge of the
biological and the evolutionary basis of
at least the first two personality
traits,
say extroversion and neuroticism,
roughly corresponding to positive and
negative emotion.
So,
um,
so that's partly why you're reading grey
and grey theories.
Also cybernetic theory.
Cybernetic theory is a,
is a variation of a theory developed by
an mit cognitive scientist named Norbert
Wiener,
who,
who was an early ai artificial
intelligence researcher.
And he proposed that,
that,
that intelligent entities were goal
directed and that they organize their
behavior around reducing deviations from
a goal.
Well they were approaching it once they
had decided what it would be.
Now that's also proved to be incredibly
influential.
Um,
we'll talk a fair bit about cybernetic
models as we progress.
Um,
so gray is sort of a combination of
artificial intelligence,
cybernetic theorizing and then an
incredible amount of data that's come in
from animal behavioral research.
And as far as I'm concerned,
most of the things that we know about
the brain have been derived from animal
research.
Um,
the animal researchers tended to be
extraordinarily careful scientists.
They were influenced by um,
um,
be bf skinner who established the sort
of the initial
theoretical basis for understanding how
animals learn.
We'll talk about that a little bit next
class.
So anyways,
that's the,
that's the context within which gray is
working.
Luddu these are all papers you're going
to read except the third one,
which is optional.
Luddu is also an emotional,
he's an effect of neuroscientists.
So He's a someone who studies emotions
mostly.
Again,
animals and Luddu has done a lot to sort
of add some of the pieces that were
missing in,
in gray gray probably concentrated a
little bit too much on a brain area
called the hippocampus,
which is the brain area that sort of
lets you know if it's reasonable to be
calm where you're currently situated.
And so what the hippocampus does in some
sense is compare what it is that you
want to have happen with what is
happening.
And if the two things are the same,
then you're comp.
So it's a match mismatch detector and it
has access not only to memory but also
two formulations of say the desired
future.
Um,
Swanson,
I had people read the Swanson paper last
year,
I put it in your reading list is
optional.
Um,
it's worth hacking through if you can
manage it.
It's very hard paper though,
which is why it took it out of the
required reading list.
The reason I like Swanson,
we're going to talk fair bit about him
today is
Swanson's not a psychologist.
He's actually a developmental neuro.
I can never say this properly.
And
he studies developmental anatomy,
we'll,
we'll do that.
Um,
and so he's very interested in how the
brain unfolds across time during
embryonic development and then up into
maturity.
And so he understands the brain
differently than a psychologist would
because a psychologist tends to analyze
the brain,
you know,
as a sort of mature thing usually in
adulthood but,
but for Swanson it's a much more living
and transforming system and he's trying
to set forth a Schema for understanding
brain anatomy and also associating that
with function.
You know,
and you might think that that's a well
advanced science already that we know
how to segment up the brain and we know,
you know roughly what the piece is due.
But we haven't even really managed to
establish the terminology pro property
yet.
It's very neuro neuroscience is a very
new field and,
and there's no limit to the number of
things that we don't know about it,
including even the basic classification
structure.
Now Swanson has put forth a very
intelligent basic classification
structure.
And part of the reason that I think it's
so relevant to a personality class is
because it maps in a beautiful way onto
some of the things that we've already
talked about,
especially piaget.
So there's a nice direct mapping of
Piaget's developmental theory onto
Swanson's theory of neurodevelopment and
then of neural function.
And that's completely accidental because
Swanson never cites piaget,
so they're non overlapping literature.
So I kind of liked that because you
know,
if something pops up in one place with
one method and pops up another place
with a completely different method,
especially if those two places are
distinct in terms of their historical
development,
you might start thinking there's
actually something there.
You know,
it's sort of like seeing something in
hearing it.
At the same time you've got two
independent sources of data.
It's like triangulation in a sense.
And so it was very exciting to me to
come across this paper by Swanson.
Um,
I think he's one of only two scientists
I ever wrote a fan letter too.
I mean,
really it's a brilliant paper.
And then,
uh,
there's,
there's other reasons why it maps onto
what we're going to talk about too,
because Swanson also points out quite
clearly the function of the,
he's kind of roughly separates the
hypothalamus into two halves.
And,
uh,
he points out that they have quite
distinct functions and the functions
also map onto some of the things that
we've been talking about it in a very
lovely way.
And so there's a lot of reasons to,
to go through Swanson's paper carefully.
You know,
it's like 50 pages long,
but the guy put it in some sense,
his whole life's work is in those 50
pages.
So,
you know,
even if it takes you 12 hours or 20
hours to read it,
it's like,
that's not too bad.
If you're going to extract out like 30
years solid research.
Gray's book is the same.
Like,
do you read that book you've got,
if you read it and understand it,
you've basically got a fair chunk of
neuro anatomy,
a lot of animal behavioral analysis.
So,
um,
behaviorism in general,
a lot of psychopharmacology and a lot of
understanding of the functional
significance of the brain's major.
Neurotransmitter systems.
You can get all of that from gray's
book.
That's,
that's a killer book.
You know,
if you can extract all that out.
So anyways,
carver and Scheier also take a
cybernetic perspective.
Fundamentally,
they're more cognitive scientists.
You're going to find their paper a
little bit farther down the road,
but they're also very interested in how
creatures,
human beings in particular select goals
and then align themselves with those
goals.
And for our purposes,
we're going to talk a fair bit about
motivation today.
And the distinction between motivation
and emotion is not clear.
They're both words that sort of function
within an linguistic context.
But for the sake of argument,
and of course all the emotions aren't
the same.
It's not like there's one circuit that
subsumes emotion.
There's multiple circuits that subsume
emotion and they're not identical
circuits,
you know?
So it isn't like every emotion is a
variant of the same thing.
It's not.
And it's the same with the motivation.
So they're very loose groupings,
motivation and emotion.
But for the purposes of our argument,
we're going to make this case roughly
motivations,
set goals and roughly emotions orient
you in relationship to those goals.
Now,
like I said,
those categories overlap.
Anger is usually considered an emotion
and it often has a goal,
right?
The goal is to hit something or hurt
something.
That's one possible goal.
So emotions can segway quite easily into
motivational states,
but whatever.
You got to use a category system of some
sort to clear clarify things.
And so that's what we're going to,
we're going to,
uh,
pursue motivations,
set goals.
It's actually more complicated than
that.
You know,
I showed you that little oval diagram
with a desired future and unbearable
present,
so to speak.
Motivations actually don't just set
goals,
they also prime behavior and they also
set up the perceptual frame within which
you interpret the world.
So for example,
if you're hungry and isn't just that
you're driven to eat,
first of all,
eating is a very complex behavior,
especially if it's associated with food
preparation.
Say you're the,
the systems that you've used in the past
to procure food and then to ingest it
are sort of disinhibited by the
motivational state.
So they're at the ready and then your
sensory system is tuned so that it's
going to focus on those things that are
relevant to eating and tune out
everything else.
So the motivational state also does
perceptual tuning and there's a felt
component of it as well.
So it's not,
it's,
it's not reasonable to only say that
motivation sets goals or that it drives
behavior.
It does three things,
goal setting,
behavioral driving,
plus it provides a perceptual schema
within which those other two things make
sense.
And so a motivated state in some sense
is like a little micro personality.
It's only got one aim.
It's sort of a one eyed micro
personality,
you know,
so it's only aiming at one thing,
but it still has all the other aspects
of personality.
So
sort of,
you know,
for me that that aligns nicely with the
psychoanalytic idea that you know,
you're,
you're a,
you're a loose aggregation of multiple
fragmented personalities.
You know,
they're sort of coherently tied together
at the highest level of analysis,
but they can go off and do their own
thing.
You see that in situations,
for example,
like eating disorders where the hunger
system itself starts to become almost a
spun off part of the personality and the
rest of the personality.
Then wars with that.
And that's sort of in some sense that's
like cortex versus hypothalamus and you
never win.
CORTEX does not win over hypothalamus.
The hypothalamus is what keeps you
alive.
So that's one of the things that keeps
you alive.
You could do without your cortex,
but you cannot do without your
hypothalamus.
And the connections stretching upwards
from the hypothalamus,
which is a very old brain area,
are much more powerful than the
connections coming down from the cortex
to modulate the hypothalamus.
And that's another indication of just
exactly who's in charge when the chips
are down,
you know?
And that's why it's so hard for you to
override your basic emotions or
motivational states.
It's like the system evolved to keep you
alive and it's not particularly willing
to give up control in a sense given that
your survival is staked on its function.
So
it's useful to know that because you
know,
if you,
if you pursue psychology and you stay
within the human side of psychology,
say instead of wandering off into the
animal behavioral research,
you'll see that most human psychologists
and neuropsychologists are very cortical
centric.
They really like to think that it's the
newly evolved parts of the brain that
are in charge and that's just not right.
The newly evolved parts of the brain are
in charge only when nothing is bothering
you.
Like if you're not hungry,
you're not thirsty,
you're not too excited,
you're not too curious.
You're not too terrified.
You know,
you're not too cold,
you're not too warm any of those,
then the cortex is in charge.
But if you deviate substantially across
any of those dimensions,
the probability that control over your
behavioral output in your perceptions,
it's going to devolve down the
evolutionary hierarchy to more
primordial brain areas is extremely
likely.
You know,
and you see the same thing happens.
maybe you're having a discussion with
someone,
right?
And they exhaust the limits of your
rational knowledge,
which means basically they out argue,
well what happens?
Well usually what happens is that people
cry or they get angry and it's like
they're out of cortex.
It's bang right down to the more,
the lower and more primary
evolutionarily determined systems.
So okay,
now we're going to,
we're going to take a look at how the
brain functions in general.
And so we're going to start pretty
general and then we're going to go
narrow.
And the first thing that you might want
to think about is what problem exactly
is the brain wrestling with.
And the major problem is that reality is
so complicated.
It has so many layers and so many
interconnected causal links that it's
complex beyond comprehension.
And that's a big problem.
I mean,
you think about all the subatomic
complexity,
that's a horrible thing.
Then there's the complexity at the
atomic level and that's,
you know,
pretty overwhelming.
And then there's the molecular level,
which makes the atomic level looks
simple.
And then there's all the comp
exceedingly complex structures that
emerge out of the molecular level,
especially in living organisms.
So that would be roughly at the organ
level of existence,
you know,
and then there's you as a totality with
your brain,
which is,
and the brain is so much more complex
than everything else in the universe
that it's not even in the same category.
So there are estimates,
for example,
by Gerard Edelman,
that there are more connections in your
brain,
more patterns of connections in your
brain than there are subatomic particles
in the universe.
So,
you know,
that's one major league complex thing
and there's lots of them around and you
know,
they're all integrated into families.
And then,
uh,
you know,
roughly tribal grouping,
some of which get large enough to be
nations.
And then that's all embedded inside of
some biological system and so on and so
forth,
all the way out to the limits of the
cosmos.
I mean,
this is one complicated place and you
know,
your job in,
in large part is to understand it,
but also not to become overwhelmed by it
because you have to simplify it down to
the point where you can sort of think
about one thing and do one thing.
And so you have to screen all of that
out so that the complexity,
complexity doesn't overwhelm you when
you're attempting to do anything,
anything simple even to look at yourself
in the mirror,
which is also a very complicated thing
to do.
Part of the problem your brain is,
is always facing is
what can I ignore?
And the answer to that is,
well,
you need to ignore almost everything.
And,
and that's,
that's a problem because of course it's
not always obvious what it's okay,
what's okay for you to ignore,
you know?
And that changes on you suddenly too,
because you know,
because you have imperfect knowledge,
you may think something's irrelevant and
it turns out to be of critical
importance.
It's deadly.
It's a deadly,
deadly difficult problem.
And so one of the ways that we solve
this is we're actually blind to,
to,
to almost everything.
You know,
our sensory
input is limited by our physiological
limitations,
certainly.
So there's like,
in terms of vision,
we only see a very small,
just a little slice of the whole
electromagnetic spectrum.
And it's the same with sounds.
And you know,
we can only touch things that are
basically within our reach.
And so that limits things substantially.
And then there are also things we can't
detect.
Like we're not very good at detecting,
um,
like we don't have the same ability that
say it was said platypuses and some fish
can detect electromagnetic disturbances
around them,
on their skin and like their senses that
we don't have.
So we'reZ ,
we're narrowed a fair bit by what it is
that we're able to perceive.
Um,
and we're actually narrowed,
okay.
In what we can perceive far more than
anybody ever.
Guests.
So I'm going to show you a little video
here and,
uh,
hopefully it will be loud enough so that
you can hear it.
Okay.
16 passes.
Did you spot the gorilla
for people who hadn't seen or heard
about it?
Did you like this before?
About half miss the gorilla.
If you knew about the gorilla,
you probably saw it,
but did you notice the curtain changing
color or the player on the black team
leaving the game?
[inaudible]
there goes a player is changing from red
to gold.
You've offered this other,
the invisible gorilla.com.
So how many of you saw the gorilla?
No,
let's,
let's do it.
The,
okay.
Yeah.
How many of you had known about this
video beforehand?
Yeah,
the gorilla part of it.
Yeah.
So you guys don't count now.
And then,
you know,
I get someone who's seen it before and
they still miss the damn gorilla.
So that's pretty funny.
So,
but,
but of course Simon,
Dan Simon set this up because his
original video got so popular,
you know,
virally popular that everybody has seen
the invisible gorilla.
And so,
you know,
now he's showing you that while you
think you're smart,
you've been clued in to how blind you
are and it turns out you're not any
smarter than you are to begin with.
Right.
So how many people saw all three things
that changed?
Oh,
you've seen it before.
So,
okay.
And how many didn't?
Okay.
Yeah.
So the vast majority of you missed one
or more of the things that change?
No,
in the,
not really trivial things like the
disappearance of a person from six
people that's fairly major and you know,
the whole background changed color and
you might think you'd clue into that.
And so,
so the weird thing is even when you're
primed to notice what you're supposed to
notice,
which is to say count the balls and you
know that something weird is going to
happen,
you're not,
that's still doesn't prime you enough so
that you can keep track of all the weird
things that are happening.
And like this was an absolutely
staggering experiment when,
when it was first shown,
the psychologist were just like knocked
over by it because the hypothesis up to
that point had been always that,
you know,
you could concentrate on what you were
concentrating on,
but if something anomalous or unexpected
happened,
your attention would be automatically
devoted towards it.
And of course that's what people would
think,
right?
You'd think that if you're watching
people play basket ball and a gorilla
walks into the you know,
area and it's not small that of course
you'd be surprised and you'd see it and
it turns out that that's just wrong.
And you know,
it tells you a lot about how your
nervous system is set up.
So you're focusing on counting the
balls.
And so for some reason getting the
correct answer to the question,
how many times are the,
is the ball thrown back and forth turns
out to be motivationally significant?
Why?
Yeah.
Like why,
why,
why did you,
you know,
you got the instructions.
Fair enough.
But why did you listen to them?
Oh sure it does.
But the question is why did you even
comply with the instructions?
Yeah.
Who said that?
Because you want to get the answer
right.
Why did you care if you got the answer
right?
Well think about it for a minute.
Like what yes means yes.
Ah,
that's right.
So that's one possibility.
It's like instantly you sort of
interpreted as a little cognitive tasks
maybe,
and then you want to see if you can do
it.
And you know also that taps into your
hierarchy of values.
Part of your value is I want to be maybe
a smart and competent person or I want
to be at least as smart and competent as
everyone else is playing this game.
And so you know,
the instruction taps into a preexistent
value structure and then it's
motivating.
Okay.
So Yup.
What compliance as well.
Yes.
That's another thing.
It's like the,
you know,
the room in some ways it's set up to
ensure a degree of,
right?
Because there's an,
there's an implicit story in the room,
which is if I'm at the front of it.
And so that sort of makes me at the top
of the dominance hierarchy and the fact
that you're here means you've already
bought into that presupposition.
And so it's a logical thing to do to
play along with the game.
So yes.
Yeah,
true.
That that's more like the playing a game
issue,
right?
Is that while maybe something
interesting will happen.
Okay.
Right,
right,
right.
Okay.
So there's a variety of reasons why you
might listen to the instructions,
but the point is the instructions
actually tap into your motivation in
your intrinsic motivation enough so that
you will in fact attempt to play the
game.
And then as soon as you play the game,
what happens while you focus your very
limited attentional resources precisely
on what it is that you're supposed to
do.
Now we could talk a little bit about how
the visual field,
it's set up.
So you know,
you,
you notice that like if I'm looking
around the room,
if I want to see you,
all of you,
I can't just stand here and look
straight ahead because all you people
over here,
you're like,
I can't see if I'm looking straight
ahead.
I can't see the faces of anyone past
here and I can only see them sort of as
blurs and unless they move and if they
move up something then I can see the
movement.
But I can't,
it's not clear to me what's moving.
And it's the same for the people over
here.
The only person I can really see right
now is the,
is the woman who's sitting there in the
white sweater.
All the rest of you are like,
and the person to the right.
I can more or less,
as long as I look at her,
I could more or less see that he's
dressed in gray,
but I can't see his face at all now as
he nodded his head and I could pick that
up.
So what's very strange about your visual
system and your sensory systems are like
this in,
in,
uh,
you know all your sensory systems are
like this is that you have a tiny little
point of focus where the information is
rich.
And that's partly because,
so the center of your eye is the full vr
and it's most densely,
ah,
it's most densely packed with cells.
But more importantly,
each of the cells in your phobia,
which is the very center of your vision,
you can tell when someone's pointing
their full view for via at you because
then you,
you know,
you have the sense that they're looking
at you and human beings are unbelievably
good at figuring out when someone is
pointing their full via at u w we can,
we can detect I um,
what would you call it?
Deviation from direct gaze with an
accuracy that's absolutely remarkable.
Now each of those little cells in the
phobia is connected.
Each of the one sells is connected to
like 20,000 cells at the first level of
the hierarchy of the visual system.
And so the reason that your whole high
isn't full vs cause your head would have
to be this big to manage it.
So you know w what's evolved is sort of
a compromise is that in the center of
your vision it's the center of your
vision is very detailed.
And,
and then what you do is you zip that
center around like snap,
snap,
snap.
And your brain sorta makes a amalgamated
picture out of all those little
snapshots and you know,
then it weaves it together.
So it seems to you like it's a
continuous what a continuous movie of
consciousness even though it's really
not.
And then the sides of your eyes,
the periphery of your eyes.
Well they don't have the same potency as
the full via and so they,
they kind of play a triage game.
It's like,
okay,
I can't see if I'm looking straight
ahead,
I can't see everything.
What might I use as an indication that I
should move my gaze from where I'm
looking to somewhere else.
And one answer to that is movement.
So the periphery is pretty good at
picking up movement.
And so often if you see movement in the
periphery,
then you'll move your fovial vision to
where the movement was and then you
know,
then you can keep track of what's
changing.
So what your brain sort of assumes is
that when you're looking at something,
everything else is irrelevant.
And it's also,
it also sort of fades into the
background.
And so that's what's happening with the
gorilla video.
And so the part of the reason you can't
see the damn gorillas cause he's dressed
in black like the players.
And so when you're focusing on the
basketball,
all the block moving things look the
same.
You know,
there's no distinction between them at
all.
And then the background of the curtain,
it's like,
well first of all,
why would you be primed to see the
curtain change color?
Like things just don't do that in real
life,
right?
I mean,
big objects don't suddenly change color
very,
very seldomly.
So,
and Bob and more importantly,
the fact that the gorilla shows up,
the fact that one player leaves and the
fact that the curtains change color has
no bearing whatsoever on whether or not
you can complete the task.
Right?
So it doesn't matter if you ignore the
information and that's because it's
irrelevant in terms of the interpretive
frame,
the motivated interpretive frame that
you're applying to the scene.
And so the rule for perception is don't
pay attention to anything that isn't
directly relevant to the desired
outcome.
Now exactly how you calculate what you
can pay attention to and what you can't.
That's very complicated.
It's,
I mean,
you build that knowledge bit by bit over
time and,
and you can be wrong about it too.
But,
um,
so,
so the old idea was,
you know,
well first of all that you were very
much conscious of the environment
period,
which you're not.
And then the second idea was,
well,
while you're being conscious of the
environment,
if anything changes radically,
you will definitely focus your attention
on it.
And then,
and what turned out to be the case is,
well,
you're not very conscious of the
environment and radical things can
happen and you won't notice them unless
they interfere with what you're doing.
So something that emerges that
interferes with what you're doing that
you don't expect,
you will instantly orient towards and
concentrate on.
So it isn't a normally or novelty that
attracts your attention.
It's the unexpected disruption of the
relationship between your behaviors and
the desired outcome of those behaviors.
And that's a much narrower claim.
Only pay attention to things that make
you fail.
It's something like that,
or at least additionally,
pay attention to things that make you
fail.
And you know,
generally speaking,
that's also associated with an emotional
response.
You know?
So if you're doing something and,
and you know,
you think you know how to do it,
and so you're doing it and then all of a
sudden something unexpected happens,
you're going to have an emotional
reaction.
And we'll talk more about the emotional
reactions in the next class.
But the emotional reaction partly
prepares you for the worst in case this
unexpected thing is bigger than you
think it is.
And sort of also primes you to be
curious and to start to explore,
to figure out what it is so that you can
reconstruct your expectations and
desires in accordance with the
transforming world.
So
this slide is an elaboration in some
sense of what I was telling you a little
bit earlier about the multiple levels of
reality.
You know,
so the idea is that the thing that you
see,
which in this particular schema would be
the computer
is nested inside all of these systems or
has other systems nested inside of it.
And that's part of an indication of the
complexity of things.
Now,
you know,
one of the things that you might think
about,
for example,
if you're using your computer,
okay,
one of the things you might ask yourself
is like,
why is your computer a black rectangle?
There are like a silver rectangle.
It's all smooth and shiny.
Why is that?
You know,
like it's not clear.
First it's not transparent.
Okay.
And,
and then it's got this smooth cover.
And it wouldn't necessarily have to.
Why?
Why do you think that's appealing to
you?
Okay,
so it's familiar.
Yeah,
that,
that's good.
So it's familiar.
What,
what else is,
it's simple.
Yeah.
You don't want to,
you don't want to interact with the
computer at all.
You want to attract with little pictures
on the screen and then you don't even
really want to interact with those.
You want to interact with some subset of
what that picture is doing on the
screen.
And so you're very,
very rarely using the computer,
right?
You're just paying attention to,
well let's say the screen and the
keyboard.
So the computer is whatever's underneath
that.
And then what,
what that is is a collection of parts
that are so bloody complicated that you
don't want to have anything to do with
them that are nested inside a whole
network of things that are so complex.
You don't want to have anything to do
with them.
And so,
so you know what happens when you're
using a computer is all of a sudden it
stops working.
Well then it's a computer.
As soon as it stops working,
it's a computer.
Before that it was whatever it was you
were doing.
And as soon as it turns into a computer,
what do you do with it?
Well,
you know,
you stupidly hit the on and off button
and they'd be a plug it in and and you
know and out or something and maybe you
checked your switches to make sure that
a fuse didn't burn out or a break or go
and that's pretty much the end of you in
terms of your ability to deal with the
actual entity,
you know,
and then you curse with your primate
brain and then you send it out to be
fixed.
And so one of the things that's,
that's that's worth considering because
this will also help us understand what
happens in terms of brain function as we
go along is that as long as things are
going according to how you want them to
go,
you can really pretend that the world is
unbelievably simple.
All the world consists of is those few
things that you're doing in your little
bounded perceptual frame and everything
else is zero.
And then unfortunately now and then the
hypothesis that everything else is zero
is radically wrong.
Like when your computer crashes and then
you actually actually for awhile have to
deal with at least some of the
complexity that's actually there.
And that's usually extremely anxiety
provoking.
So you know,
you can imagine in the same situation is
while you're in your nice smooth car and
you're on the highway and all of a
sudden,
you know,
you hear a horrible grinding noise and
smoke comes out of the back and you're,
you're off pulled over to the side.
Well,
what was merely a means of getting from
point a to B and comfort like two
seconds ago,
is now a collection of extremely
troublesome parts,
none of which you know anything about.
Plus it's disrupted your day,
plus it's disrupted your pocket book.
Plus you have to now deal with a bunch
of people who are going to tell you
what's wrong with your vehicle and maybe
fix it for some completely unknown
amount of money and with dubious
utility.
And so poof,
the car turns into that.
And so it's,
it's almost impossible to overestimate
the degree to which we live within a
world that's bounded by our expectations
and desires and how much time we spend
keeping everything that's complex away
from us so that we don't have to deal
with it.
Okay,
so now we might want to think about how
we do that.
I'm going to show you,
this is the little Schema that might be
helpful.
So like
I made this little diagram of dots
because I wanted to make an ambiguous
figure.
So I'm hoping that when you look at that
figure,
what do you see when you look at it?
The center and what?
What?
What shape is the center
across?
Okay,
so you can see across.
What else can you see?
It's a rectangle.
Yeah.
What else?
Can you see?
What square?
It's four squares.
Yeah,
exactly.
So what else can you see?
That's a good one.
I haven't seen that one.
I'll take your word for it though.
What else can you see?
I'll show you some of the things you can
see.
Okay.
Yeah.
You see that,
right?
You see that?
See that?
You could see that.
Okay.
So the first thing that you might know
is that
the thing in the beginning,
the thing in itself,
let's say you can see milk multiple
ways.
It's not exactly that.
You have an opinion about what it is,
you know,
it's the,
you can actually see those different
things.
You can see it manifesting those
different perceptual objects.
And that,
that's a strange thing because you know
how people always think that arguments
are about opinions.
There's some facts and you have one set
of opinions about them and you have
another,
and then you argue about the opinions
till you get to the facts.
Unfortunately,
it's a lot worse than that because the
facts themselves are often reasonably
subject to debate.
So you,
so you might ask for example,
which of the five ways that you could
see that initial thing is the right way
to see it.
And the answer to that,
and this is a pragmatic answer,
is it depends on what you want to do
with your perception.
You know?
So if you want to,
if you wanted the highest resolution
that captures as much detail as
possible,
then you want something as close to the
thing in itself as possible.
So that'd probably be object fives
there.
You know,
if you want to know the rough area,
let's say that's a map of an orchard,
you might think about object one.
If it's an orchard from the top right
and you want it to walk from north to
south,
you might want to think about it in
terms of object three you know,
and so those are different ways you can
perceive that object.
And then I would say that what happens
at the next level of abstraction,
and that's where you've got the numbers
and words down here,
is that you have the thing in itself
which is complex and can be seen many
ways.
Then you have the things you see which
are partial,
sort of low resolution representations
of the thing itself.
And then there are words which are at
least in part references to the image of
the thing.
And so by the time you get to the word,
it's pretty compressed.
And I really liked the metaphor of
compression,
you know,
so cause a lot of the things you see are
sort of like thumbnails and why our
thumbnails useful.
You guys have done some,
you know,
image processing.
Say like obviously a thumbnail lacks
some things that a 16 megabyte is that
about right now?
How big are cameras?
16 megabytes for a single photo.
What's that?
Yeah,
well I think the new cameras are up.
I think they're up to 16 the newest
iteration.
So,
okay.
So why have thumbnail if you have a 16
megabyte picture?
Okay,
okay.
But why not use the picture,
right?
That's exactly it is that there's a
trade off between detailed
representation and time utilization time
and resource utilization.
And you know like,
like a computer,
you guys have limited time and resources
and so you don't actually want to see
any more than you need to see in order
to get what you're supposed to get done
done.
Because otherwise it's just a waste of
energy.
And so what that means is that your
brain is always trying to figure out in
some sense what's the simplest way I can
represent this so that I can undertake
whatever it is that I'm planning to
undertake next.
And that sort of,
again,
from a philosophical perspective,
that's actually something pragmatic.
Okay.
So then you might ask yourself,
you organize your perceptions in
relationship to your goals,
and then you might ask yourself,
well,
where do those goals come from?
And when we've,
we've heard from thinkers like say Freud
who talked about the ied functions in
the Ed is sort of the seat of primordial
impulses,
right?
And so you might,
it might think about the Ed as the
producer of primary goals or drives and
for,
I did think about them as drive.
So they were things that led to,
you know,
a relatively rigid behavioral algorithm
once the,
the state had arisen.
Now,
as I mentioned before,
I think that that's a flawed viewpoint
because the motivational state is more
than merely a drive because the drive is
something that say triggers a
preprogrammed sequence of behaviors.
And a lot of the early behaviorists
thought about animal behavior in that
weight,
right?
They'd say the animal encounter a
stimulus and the stimulus would produce
a response and then the responses would
get chained together.
And then when the animal look
encountered the stimulus again,
then just those change responses would
automatically run.
And one of the famous experiments that
showed that that was wrong was a rat was
trained to run through a maze.
You could sort of train your out pretty
quickly if you know you,
you put them in the maze and there's
like he can go this way or this way and
you put some cheese over here,
you do that three or four times the rat
learns to turn right.
And then you add another piece to the
maze and you know,
then the rattlers to turn left.
And so you can get it turning,
you know,
extremely in an extremely complicated
way to walk through the maze.
But then what they did was they took a
rat and they wrapped up its hind legs,
you know,
like with tape.
So it couldn't use them.
And then they put its little rear end on
a cart and then they had the little rat
scoot through the maze on the cart.
And it's obvious that a scooting route
and a running route don't use the same
motor output,
not even close.
And the rat could still get the maze.
So the idea that all the route had done
was chained together,
learned automatic responses,
turned out to be wrong.
Rats,
it's more like rats learn what's going
on and can generalize from it just like
you do so.
So anyway,
so,
so the notion that the drive just
instantiates a sequence of preprogrammed
behaviors in most cases,
in many cases,
especially with complex behavior,
it turns out to be wrong.
There's some limited circumstances under
which it's right.
Okay.
So the first hypothesis we're going to
entertain is the idea that you have to
frame the world in order to interact
with it.
And this is sort of a little
mythological diagram that I whipped up a
long time ago.
And the bottom thing that's a neuro
bruce,
by the way,
which is a dragon that eats its own
tail.
It's an ancient symbol of chaos and
chaos is what you see when you don't
know what you're looking at.
And so you could say in some sense chaos
is all the complexity that surrounds you
that
could possibly intrude on your little
safe world.
And then
to grasp that k also to operate within
it,
you have to put it within a framework.
And so that's the great father there.
That's actually God you see in God's got
the sun behind him because God is like
the sun,
he's you know,
reliable and he's associated with
consciousness and then he sorta ruling
over this city.
And so for me that was a good symbol of
culture and put in part culture is
what's outside of you.
But in part culture is also the
frameworks that you've learned to use by
being with other people.
The frameworks that you've learned to
use to narrow and specify the world.
And in my motive thinking that framing
is a associated with security on the one
hand because it tells you what you can
do and you know it makes things safe for
you.
And tyranny on the other hand,
cause it can get out of control and you
know,
you can start to get too rigid,
whatever,
regardless of the pros and cons of
framing.
If you see something one way,
then you can't see it another,
it's harder to see it another.
So that's the corn side of framing the
pros side of framing is while it then
you get to do something.
If it's unframed you're in chaos,
it's existential anxiety,
you're not going to move ahead at all.
So you have to frame things,
you have to simplify them.
And really in some sense you even have
to oversimplify them.
Depends on what you mean by that.
But what you're really trying to do is
to never make your perceptual task any
more complex than that has to be in
order to get done what you need to get
done.
So how do you frame things?
Well,
the first thing we should point out is
that a lot of framing,
it doesn't even happen psychologically,
right?
So here you are sitting in this
classroom and you're not overwhelmed by
chaos.
Well why?
Well,
first of all,
you're in a city that's helpful.
There's electricity here and there's
natural gas and there's people to fix
all the plumbing.
And so the fact that you're in a city
makes life much simpler.
Right off the bat.
There's nothing trying to eat you.
You don't have to contend with the fact
that it's like minus 20 for three
months.
And you know,
so that's a whole bunch of complexity
that the were,
the civilized world is just taken care
of for you.
And then,
you know,
now you're in the university in the city
and that eliminates a whole bunch of
other hassles.
You know,
there's some things you have to do,
but there's a bunch of things you don't
have to do and then you're inside this
building and wow,
look at that.
There's electric light here and you
know,
and the chairs work and there's not
going to be an earthquake.
And probably the whole building isn't
going to fall down.
So you know,
by the time you sitting in your chair
here also with your clothing on,
you've screened a lot of complexity out
already.
And so you can sit there fairly calmly.
And so that's all external.
Now part of the reason,
and this is this is where thinking
about,
because this isn't only psychological,
you guys will hear a fair bit about
terror management theories as you
progress through your education.
And so Karen Management theories are
theories that attempt to account for why
people are,
uh,
say patriotic in their beliefs,
why they adopt belief systems.
And the idea is that a belief system
protects you from death anxiety.
And so Freud's are sorta said that about
religious systems.
That was his critique of religion.
People are afraid of death.
And so they have this infant title
desire to have that fear go away.
So they turned to religion and religion
says,
well,
death isn't permanent.
And that's why people are religious.
And the extension of that is,
well,
that's also why they have belief systems
in general.
They're trying to protect themselves
against this deep shaking anxiety.
And to some degree,
I suspect that's true.
But you should also remember that when
you're protecting your culture,
say if you identify with it,
you're patriotic or whatever it is,
or you think that your culture is worth
defending.
You're not just defending something
psychological.
It's like the culture,
the function,
the key functioning culture keeps the
lights on,
you know,
so it doesn't just protect you from
death anxiety.
It also protects you from death.
And that's even more important most of
the time than being protected from death
anxiety.
Now there's a psychological component to
it too,
but you don't ever want to underestimate
just the practical utility of being
nested inside.
You know what piaget would consider a
relatively functional game.
It's like your words a lot simpler,
you know,
you have to work to maintain it and
everything,
and that's kind of a drag.
Maybe that's the tyrannical element of
it,
but you know,
the payoff's pretty big.
Okay?
So if you look at medieval cities,
this is a well preserved medieval city
in France.
There's a lot of medieval cities that
still exist in Europe.
And you see this is a typical sort of
human habitation.
It's like inside there's order and
outside there's chaos and barbarians and
then there's a couple of walls to keep
the chaos and the barbarians out.
And then inside,
you know,
there's a dominance hierarchy and
everybody can live their relatively
productive and relatively peaceful
lives.
Inside of that,
it's all framing,
getting rid of complexity,
unnecessary complexity.
Same thing with houses.
They do the same for you.
And then social institutions do the same
thing too.
It's like,
okay,
this is,
uh,
is it Kennedy there and,
and Obama?
I think so this is part of the
transition in power from George Bush to
Obama.
And you know,
that's a pretty scary thing to have.
You're the leader of your dominance
hierarchy replaced by another leader and
you know,
among chimpanzees for example,
that's often the occasion for a fair bit
of mayhem.
And it's also the case often for people
that that's,
you know,
that that occurs and you know,
we still have that in the form of
political corruption and so on.
But all things considered,
you know,
the power transition from Obama or from
Bush to Obama was far more peaceful than
such.
Power transitions generally are if you
look across the history of mankind.
And so that means you're also protected
by your social institutions.
They screen out a lot of potential
complexity as well,
as long as they're functional.
And,
and also I think as long as they follow
some of the Piaget and rules.
And so one of the PSG in rules for a,
for a playable game is there's some
reciprocity.
You know,
you regard the system roughly speaking
as either fair or fairer than any other
system you can think up.
You know,
it boils down to the same thing because
if it's not fair,
but you can't come up with a better
fantasy,
well it's as good as it can be.
So,
so the,
the sociological or sociopolitical
structures that keep complexity away
from us can only operate under a certain
limited number of constraints.
But still they perform their function,
you know,
and,
and very admirably.
It's,
it's amazing I think,
because I see people in my clinical
practice all the time,
you know,
and most people that I see,
and I think this is true of most people
in the world have at least one serious
problem,
you know,
and it might be they have an illness
that's just god awful.
Or if or if they don't have an illness,
one of their immediate family has an
illness that's god awful.
Or they're,
you know,
they're really old and they're,
and they need to be taken care of or
they're suffering from some insane
economic problem or they've just been
unemployed or whatever.
You know,
there's,
there's something in the,
their immediate circle that's really,
really difficult to grapple with.
And yet people still go out and maintain
their place in the world and the whole
thing roughly works.
And to me that's just a con continual
source of amazement that people can pull
that off,
you know?
So anyway,
so a lot of the screening that you do to
get rid of that complexity is external
and part of that is a consequence of
good,
well functioning,
sociological,
um,
organization.
Then the next thing that sorta screens
things out for you is your body.
Right now,
look,
you kind of naturally see things at a
particular level of resolution,
right?
There's no obvious reason why that
should be.
So you know,
you see the front of people,
you can't see the back of them.
You see their external covering,
their skin in their clothes,
can't see inside them.
When you look closely at them,
you can't see their cellular structure
or their molecular structure,
their atomic structure.
You can't really see the social
situations that they're embedded in.
So if I look at you,
I can't see your family,
I,
you know,
I presume you have one.
I can't really see the political
situation that surrounds you either.
I have to know that abstractly.
And then the ecological level is almost
completely imperceptible to me.
And so part of the way that complexity
is screened out is that your body just
doesn't allow you to pick a lot of it
up.
You're just blind to it.
So you see at one level of resolution,
and that's the human level.
You see things of approximately our
size.
You see things that are approximately
the size that we can grip.
Those are sort of the things that you're
likely to come to think of as objects.
Like clearly a mountain isn't exactly an
object,
you know,
so usability is part of what defines
perceptibility.
And so that also screens things out.
And so then you're left with while what
it is that you have to deal with once
everything's been screened out.
And then you might ask,
well,
there's still a lot of complexity left
there.
Like they say,
there's plenty of complexity within the
average family and there's plenty of
complexity in the mating domain,
you know,
to find a partner and to establish a
reasonable longterm relationship and to
have children and to raise them.
There's plenty of complexity left.
And then the question is how did
biology,
how did biology come to solve those
problems?
Given that there are almost infinite and
complexity,
how can you do it?
And the answer to that is fundamentally
a Darwinian answer.
You start simple.
And so that's back in the days of the
one celled organisms,
we have no idea how those things got
their start.
Right.
I mean,
the actual beginning of life is a
serious mystery.
And I'll tell you,
it's such a serious mystery.
This is completely unbelievable.
But one of the people who discovered
DNA,
I think it was Francis Crick,
in fact,
I'm virtually certain it was,
he actually believed that DNA came from
an alien civilization.
He wrote a whole book about that.
It's called Panspermia.
And so he believes that believed
posited,
that it's possible for DNA to drift
through space for millions of years and
to land on planets and to start living.
And that to God only knows how old DNA
is because he just couldn't figure out
at all how it could have possibly
evolved.
So scientists are a lot weirder than you
think.
When you start to read,
you know about what the scientists who
discovered things really thought they're
completely,
you know,
out of their mind.
But whatever,
we'll assume that DNA got there somehow.
And then evolution took over after that.
And so what does evolution do?
It basically says,
well,
here is a terribly complex problem that
we've sort of partially solved and
partially solved means we've lived long
enough to produce another copy of
ourselves that constitutes the solution.
That's it.
So we've lived lived long enough so that
we could conceivably duplicate
ourselves.
How should we do that?
Well,
a variety of different ways.
That's the answer.
We should produce variance.
So that might be multiple offspring or
it might be,
it might also be facilitated by random
mutation.
Hypothetically,
the mutations are random,
although there's increasing evidence,
by the way,
that organisms are much more complex at
the genetic level than anyone ever
assumed.
And bacteria,
for example,
swap DNA back and forth with other
bacteria all the time.
And there are experiences that you can
have that will change your genetic
structure sufficiently so that you will
transmit that to your children.
So you know the idea that everything's
purely Darwinian and it's only mutation
that drives randomness,
that's clearly likely,
but not not complete.
These other mechanisms are clearly
there,
but the,
the,
the issue is,
is that what you do is you,
you start with something that kind of
works and then you produce micro
variants of it and then the world around
you changes a little bit and hopefully
one of those micro variants manages to
do the same thing and then it produces a
bunch of micro variants and then they
managed to do the same thing.
And so what's happening is there's an
arms race between the environment which
is always changing and the organisms
that are trying to keep up with it in
that arms race just goes on forever.
And you know,
different life forms proliferate as
that.
As that occurs,
it's sort of like life is always playing
catch up and you never get it right.
You cannot get it right.
The best you can do is get it right long
enough to live long enough to reproduce.
That constitutes the sum total of your
knowledge.
So,
and so what that means,
at least in part,
is that you guys are all the
beneficiary,
let's say,
of a evolutionary process that's
basically been going on since the
beginning of life.
And that's about 3.5 billion years ago.
And so your body,
your psychophysiology has been in an
arms race with the transforming
environment for three and a half billion
years trying to keep up and poof,
you're the stellar consequence of three
and a half billion years of like effort
and death.
So,
you know,
you might thank the cosmos about that.
You think about this,
say every single one of your female
ancestors successfully reproduced like
it's mind boggling.
It's mind boggling.
You're so unlikely that you would be
here,
that,
that it's,
that it's almost incalculable.
So good for us.
Here we are.
You know,
how successful can you get?
So my,
my point is that part of the way that
complexity is dealt with is,
is haphazard.
It isn't ever really dealt with.
That's why you die.
You can only manage it to a limited
degree.
And for us,
that's like three kids in a hundred
years.
If you're lucky.
And that's,
that's hard knowledge after three and a
half billion years.
So the complexity problem is a rough
one.
Okay,
so that's your body.
Now let's look inside your body.
Now you might think that,
you know,
we have this sort of idea that's kind of
a leftover car Tz and that there's a you
and there's a your body and the you is
in your brain.
And so just out of curiosity,
how many of you have the subjective
sense that the EU is in your head?
Okay.
How many of you would locate you?
Like for me,
I like,
I can locate me somewhere seems to be
about there.
I feel like that's where I am.
And so how many of people think have
like the center of their sense of
subjectivity in their head?
How many people are like that?
Okay.
How many people are different than that?
Okay,
so all good.
Okay.
So where like where do you feel the
center of your subjectivity?
Where would it be?
That's hard.
Oh,
I was thinking more about how?
About how it feels fair.
Fair enough.
You know that that's a perfectly
reasonable,
I'm thinking of it more as a subjective
experience though.
Okay.
And so you're kind of located here.
Yeah.
How many people would,
would agree with that?
Oh yeah.
So quite,
quite a few of you.
Wait,
so that's the same.
Same for you.
More like here?
Yeah.
Oh hmm.
Hmm.
Any other places?
Any other places you can talk about?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Sorry.
Any other places?
Oh,
that's not good.
That's fine.
No,
I'm kidding.
Okay.
So,
okay.
So we kind of gone hand in heart and you
know,
that's really kind of historically
standard.
The Greeks seem to look have located
themselves sort of in their heart,
you know,
and there's some theory that as people
became more intellectualized that that
feeling sort of went up to their head
and maybe before the heart there was the
stomach,
you know,
and you know,
you might think that you're your stomach
if you are hungry all the time.
Right.
I mean,
you're just not ever hungry.
So like,
why the hell would you think you or your
stomach?
But you know,
that's another way that culture sort of
keeps complexity at bay.
You don't even,
that's,
that's almost like a motivational state
that modern people don't even have to
contend with because you're never really
hungry.
I mean,
how many of you have gone without food
for more than 24 hours?
Oh,
that's pretty good.
How many of you in voluntarily went
without food for more than 24 hours?
Oh yeah.
Well that's,
that's rough.
Okay.
How about a week?
Nobody,
how about three days?
Okay.
Well,
so you know,
there's a couple of people who've gone
for reasonable periods of time eating,
but fundamentally you can tell we can,
we kind of got that problem under
control so you don't have to worry too
much about your,
about you being your stomach.
But I'll tell you if you were starving
at some point,
that's probably where you'd locate
yourself.
Okay.
So now you're inside the body.
And so let's take a look at how the body
works inside.
So you kind of feel that you're in your
brain,
most of you anyways,
but,
and you know,
you kind of think your brain is in your
head.
But really that's not right.
I don't really understand ever why we
kind of decided that our brains were in
our head because,
well,
look at it,
there's,
there's the nervous system.
It's like it's not in your hand.
It's distributed through your whole
body.
There's a lot of it up in your head.
But there's the whole spinal cord that's
an important thing.
And then it has all these branching
nerves that allow you to move your hands
and to feel things.
And it's like your nervous system is
distributed all the way through your
body.
So it's not reasonable to think about
the way that you operate as you see
things with your brain.
And then you do things.
Now,
if that's sort of true,
but there's important ways that it's not
true at all.
And it's important to know the ways that
it's not true.
It helps you understand phenomena that
you couldn't otherwise understand.
So I can give you an example.
There are people who experience
blindness.
So,
but it isn't because their eyes get
damaged just because they have brain
damage.
And so it damages the visual cortex.
And so that's the higher order,
higher order part of the brain that's
responsible for conscious vision.
Okay.
So maybe they get,
I dunno,
they get a tumor,
they get hit in the head or they get
shocked or something and then Poof,
they're blind.
And so then,
um,
they tell you they can't see anything
and then you say to them,
okay,
well that's fine.
You can't see anything but let's play a
game.
Okay,
I'm going to hold up my left hand or my
right hand and you're going to guess
about which I'm holding up.
And so you do this and they go,
right and you do this and they go left,
left,
right,
right.
And they're right and you tell them
you're right.
And they say,
well,
I can't because I don't see anything.
So that's one,
that's blind sight.
Okay.
So here's another kind of blind sight.
So you take the same person and you set
them in front of the screen and you say,
well,
look at the screen.
And they tell you,
I told you already I can't see anything.
And then you flash faces at them and
you,
you check for changes in the
conductivity of their skin.
Because when people react emotionally,
they sweat a little more,
a little less than that changes how
electricity passes through their skin.
So you show them a smiling face and
there's not much of a change.
And you know,
you show them a neutral face and there's
not much of a change.
And then you showed them like a really
aggressive or really afraid face and
poof spikes.
And you do that at a number of times and
you show them well.
And as soon as I show you a face of
someone who's afraid or face of someone
who's angry,
you react to it.
Psychophysiological you think,
well,
how the hell can that happen if they
can't see an answer that is,
you don't just see with your vision you
see with your body.
And so one of the things that you'll
find,
for example if you go through Swanson's
paper,
I'll read you a little bit about this
later,
is that most of your senses map onto
multiple levels of your nervous system.
So some of them knocked right onto your
spine.
And that's good because now and then
your,
I should tell your spine to do something
before you think cause is too slow.
And so,
you know,
you've got to understand like way back
when we were frogs,
roughly speaking,
we had eyes,
we didn't have much of a brain.
So like what the hell were the eyes
doing that it's not like the frog
exactly sees and you might think,
well how could eyes inform you about the
world if you don't?
Exactly see.
And then you got to kind of think of it
didn't appear as Yeti incense.
It's like
here,
here's an example.
It might take an animal like a sponge,
pretty simple animal and it can open and
close pours on the outside of its
surface according to different changes
in the ocean that surrounds it.
And so it's perception is sort of like
the ocean has three states,
whatever those might be.
Maybe it has 10 I don't know.
But for the sake of simplicity,
we'll say three.
The ocean manifest itself in three
pattern states in pattern state one I do
this in pattern state too.
I do this in pattern state three I do
this and so it's direct pattern onto
action mapping.
And so animals can use their eyes just
to react with.
You don't have to see the thing,
you know,
cause you think you see and then you
act.
But why do that?
You can just react and you know this
already because in a simple way,
if you put your hand on a hot stove,
you'll go like this and then you'll feel
the pain.
And what that means is that your body
has conserved the relationship between
your sensory neurons and your motor
neurons out of spinal level so that you
will,
your perception of the heat is this.
It's not of the heat,
it's just mapping a bodily pattern onto
a sensory pattern.
And so a lot of really primitive sensory
input is exactly that.
It's just the sense detects a pattern.
And with no intermediary of
interpretation,
that pattern is translated into a
behavioral output.
And so there's actually generally the
first,
the simplest cells or sensory motor
cells.
So they do both.
They map the pattern and they react and
then the sensory and the motor cells
differentiate and then neuro tissue
grows inside them.
And so then what happens is that instead
of an outside pattern being mapped
immediately onto a behavioral pattern,
the neuro intermediary says,
okay,
this pattern could mean that any of
these three things,
and then that neural layer grows and
grows and grows until being creatures
like us,
it's like a whopping layer.
And so we see a pattern and we go,
that could be this,
this,
this.
And then all of those things could be
mapped on to this or this or this or
this or this.
So,
you know,
it makes us more slower,
but more flexible and slow can be a
problem.
So like when you're walking down a
pathway and a snake appears,
you don't want to be thinking snake,
rubber hose,
stick,
whatever,
you know,
because then you're dead because the
snake bites you.
What you want to do is catch the snake
out of the corner of your eye and jump
up into the air before you even know
that you saw a snake.
And you can do that because your eyes
can map right onto your spine and they
don't just map right onto your spine.
They map onto your nervous system and
all sorts of levels.
So for example,
with the blind sight person who's
looking at the face,
so it's an angry face,
the eyes are still mapping information
onto the Amygdala.
And so the Amygdala changes the
psychophysiology,
you know,
it says prepare for threat.
And so the person might feel uneasy,
but that's a,
it's weird,
but that's a form of site to feel uneasy
can be a form of site.
So,
and that,
that's to say even more clearly that
your brain just isn't in your head.
It's like it's all the way up.
It's all the way from,
and this is a nice psg Eddie of
viewpoint because you know,
in some sense what Piaget says about
children is they sort of organize
themselves from the spinal level
upwards.
You know,
they learn these little sub routines.
First of all,
they have a few sub routines.
So is it like built right into the spine
and then they start playing with those
and chaining them together in flexible
ways and they keep doing that,
you know,
in more and more complex ways until
they're capable of the abstract
representation of thought.
And you can see how this will work as we
go through the,
the nervous system.
So your brains in your body,
in fact there's some evidence and there
there's more than one kind of nervous
system too,
right?
There's the central nervous system that
allows you to move voluntarily and that
you know,
provides you with sensory feedback,
some of which you're conscious of it.
There's also the autonomic nervous
system that runs your,
all the complex machinery that you're
too stupid to attend to,
you know,
cause your consciousness gets little
jobs.
It doesn't get to run your liver,
for example.
You imagine what your life would be like
if you were in charge of your liver.
It's like you'd have been dead years ago
cause what do you know about livers?
So you have a whole system like the
autonomic nervous system,
which has more neurons than the central
nervous system that just runs all that
stuff for you,
which is,
you know,
a good thing you do and then you don't
have to pay attention to it.
So,
so anyways,
there's a lot of distribution of neural
tissue throughout your body.
And there's even some evidence that you
have a like a second brain of sorts in
your solar plexus where you know,
that's perhaps part of the reason why
you really don't like to get hit there.
But there's a tremendous number of
serotonergic neurons,
for example,
in your,
in your midsection.
And there's increasing evidence that
those are associated with things like
emotion and mood.
And so the idea that the brain is here,
it's like,
mm,
no,
not,
not really.
It's,
it's a continuum.
You know,
your body is a psychophysiological
entity.
And to separate it into body and mind is
like,
it's not right.
The other thing that seems to be
increasingly clear among the say the
robotics guys is you can't even be smart
unless you have a body.
And so that's why the advanced advanced
intelligence guys are building robots
from the bottom up.
They're doing it just like piaget would
have suggested.
It's like,
well build some things that can move and
then chain those things that can move
together so that they can move in more
complex ways and then chain them
together so they can work in more
complex ways.
And once you've got this thing that can
do things,
then stick a brain on it and that'll,
then it'll have things that can do with
its brain.
And if you don't do it that way,
you get something that can't function
intelligently.
It's close to that.
So,
so there is the brain and the major one
way of dividing it into its major
subcomponents is represented.
There's a variety of ways you can do
this.
You can divide it into hemispheres
because it's sort of split down the
middle.
The right hemisphere seems to be kind of
specialized for the processing of
unknown information.
And the left seems to be more
comfortable working where you know
what's going to happen and that the left
is most generally the linguistic part of
the brain,
although not always,
it's,
it's a rough,
you know,
what would you call it?
It's a rough truth.
There's lots of exceptions.
The linguistic system tends to
specialize in the left and the left
sorta insists that it knows what's going
on.
And the right is always looking out for
things that don't fit and sort of
convincing the left slowly and sort of
under the table to change its
viewpoints.
And that seemed,
a lot of that seems to happen when
you're asleep and you're dreaming.
So the right,
maybe what's happening when you're
dreaming is that during the day your
cognitive processes are pretty tight and
defined and they better be right because
you don't want to be dreaming your
schizophrenia dreams in the daytime.
That's a bad idea.
So you gotta stay kind of focused and
narrow in a way during the day.
But the problem with that narrowed,
narrow focus is that you're not paying
attention to a lot of things.
And so it kind of looks like your right
hemisphere keeps track of the
potentially important things that you're
not keeping track of and sort of,
and then at night you're,
you're category system sort of broadens
and loosens.
You can tell that in dreams because
they're so weird.
And that's maybe when the right
hemisphere is sort of tapping some new
information into the left and playing
without how it might be recategorized
without completely overwhelming the left
because
you don't want to,
just because you learn something new,
it doesn't mean you want to upset
yourself.
Totally.
Right.
So it's a real,
it's a real complex dynamic between
stability and learning.
And it's conceivable.
That's why you have two hemispheres.
So who knows?
It's good theory though.
[inaudible] the guy who came up with it
fundamentally,
his name is Goldberg,
um,
Alconan Goldberg,
and he was a student of Alexander Luria
who was a great neuropsychologist.
So,
you know,
it's a credible,
it's credible idea.
So here's some rough divisions.
You've got your cerebellum,
that Cerebellum,
we don't know what the hell that thing
does.
If you don't have one,
you get all wobbly,
but there's more neurons in the
cerebellum and then there are in the
rest of the brain.
So like is it just making you not
wobbly?
It seems like a tremendous
devotion of resources to something
that's relatively simple.
So,
uh,
alcohol,
when you're a new drinker,
alcohol's really hard than the
Cerebellum,
which is why you're,
you know,
totally useless in a motorway and you
fall down and all those things happened.
But so that's the cerebellum and we
don't know what it does even though it's
very complex.
Lee Branch did kind of looks like a
cauliflower and it's just packed full of
neurons.
And then there's the occipital lobe and
that kind of use that to see with more
or less.
And then the prior lobe kind of keeps,
helps keep track of who,
who you are from a bodily perspective
and sort of where your body's located in
space and sort of who you are as an
embodied person.
So,
for example,
if you lose the right parietal lobe
because you have a stroke,
then you lose the left side of your
body.
And even more weirdly you lose the left
side of everything.
So all of a sudden you can't see the
left side of it anything and no one can
figure out what that's like.
Because say I'm looking at this room and
I have this pridal damage.
If I'm looking at the room,
do I not see the left side of the room?
And then if I look at you,
all of a sudden I don't see your left
side.
Like we can't figure that out.
Like the left is gone.
But then the left is relative to where
you happened to be looking.
And I think one of the ways of
understanding it is sort of like,
you know how you clearly can't see
anything behind your head and it's not
black where you can't see,
right.
It's black if you close your eyes.
But there's a difference between what
you can't see behind your head and the
black you see when you close your eyes.
Cause the block sort of seems like
nothing,
but compared to what's behind your head,
it's,
it's not nothing at all.
So I think what happens with people who
have neglect,
periodontal damages that,
that like back park just goes like this.
And so instead of you seeing this much
of the world and this being just not
there at all,
as far as vision is concerned,
it goes like this.
And so then you've only got like a
quarter of the world that you're,
and so people like that,
sometimes they'll throw their own legs
out of bed,
they wake up and they think,
oh my God,
because they can kind of detect the left
but not very well.
And they're quite freaked out because
you know,
like do you really want to wake up with
a laying in bed with,
you know,
so they grab it and throw it out and
that's not so good because they're
attached to it.
Or so they'll eat,
they'll eat and they only eat half the
food on their plate.
But if you turn the plate didn't delete
half of the half that's left.
So anyways,
that's the prior little temporal lobe
that enables you to here roughly
speaking,
there's a lot of memory there too.
And the frontal lobe,
well,
first of all,
the frontal lobe seems to allow you to
make voluntary movements sort of at the,
at the highest level of abstraction.
And then the prefrontal Cortex,
which would be right at the front of the
yellow there.
It's sort of like the back part of the,
of the frontal lobe enables you to make
voluntary movements,
but the prefrontal cortex enables you to
represent the potential motor movements
that you might make before you implement
them.
And so any evolved out of the motor
strip during the course of evolution,
it's sort of like,
well first you learn how to act
voluntarily.
And then as that grew,
and it's particularly big in human
beings,
that part was able to divorce actions
from your body,
represent them in an abstract space,
run the MS simulations,
calculate the outcome,
and then implement them or not.
And you know,
it's a,
it's a hit and miss business because
lots of you people undoubtedly simulate
catastrophic outcomes and then go do
whatever it gives you were going to do
anyways.
Like,
you know,
that happens to people all the time,
say when they're trying to stop drinking
or to stop using cocaine or not to be in
jeet or,
so you know,
your prefrontal Cortex can whip up these
simulations,
but other parts of your body can
override them quite,
quite badly.
So that's sort of roughly the brain at
least from,
you know,
looking at it from the side and then
this is it split down the middle and you
can see that it's not precisely two
hemispheres all the way down
in the middle.
It's one thing and then it grows.
These two things like little hat and uh,
as far as I'm concerned,
all the important parts of the brain are
low down,
central,
old,
you know,
because people like to think that,
well,
if they're doing evolved a long time
ago,
it's primitive.
It's like,
no,
if it evolved a long time ago,
it's been around a long time.
It's really smart.
That's why you don't run your liver.
The autonomic nervous system runs it
because it's been around for an awful
long time and it knows exactly how to do
it.
And so it's really,
in some sense the new parts of the
brains are the brain in many ways are
the parts that are primitive.
So in the old parts are extremely
necessary and sophisticated.
And so the areas we're going to
concentrate on most,
particularly our or the Cortex,
we've already talked about,
the cortex is probably responsible.
People like to think of it as
responsible for consciousness and there
there's something about that that's
right.
But it's quite clear that human beings
can remain conscious even if they have a
substantial amount of damage to the
cerebral cortex.
So consciousness is a really weird thing
where we're not very good at figuring
out where it's localized at all
cerebral cortex,
Thalamus,
the Thalamus is the place where all your
sensory information comes together.
So you know,
when you look at the world,
it's kind of like a continuum.
I've experienced despite the fact that
you have these five different sensory
inputs and the Thalamus seems to sort of
unite all that and then it sends the
messages that it amalgamates up to the
cortex and the cortex sends to the back
and the Thalamus sends them back.
And there's like this loop between the
fellows and the CORTEX.
And maybe that's part of what
consciousness is,
you know,
rather than being localized in an area,
it could easily be a process.
And you know,
the fact that consciousness sort of
turns on in the morning,
which is a very weird thing,
seems to indicate to me that it,
it's probably something like that.
It's a loop.
It's the looping interaction between
brain areas and you know,
if something's looping like that,
it gets really weird properties.
So that's a positive feedback system.
You know,
I don't know if you've ever turned a
vid,
hooked a video camera to a TV and then
turn the video camera on the TV.
You know,
it starts doing extremely weird things.
You can get all sorts of unbelievably
complex designs and weird phenomena
because the TV is recycling its own
signal.
You know?
So there's this circuit in there that's
looping and I suspect consciousness is
something like that of the hippocampus.
The hippocampus is responsible for the
movement of short term information into
longterm storage.
It's a very important part of the brain.
We'll talk about that more next time.
The amygdala is responsible for a lot of
emotional responses,
and the hypothalamus is responsible for
a lot of primordial motivational states.
And so we'll stop and we'll start with
the hypothalamus on Tuesday.
See you soon.